after years in the shadows the taliban
spokesman's face was finally revealed
zabihullah mujahid fronting for the
first taliban press conference in 20
years
as seven thousand u.s forces scrambled
to evacuate americans on military planes
the taliban called it an historic moment
taking the freedom is the right of all
nations
the afghan people by using their legal
right after 20 years of war were able to
take their freedom and clean their
country of the occupation and occupiers
while the group could not reveal who
will lead the country mujahid said talks
are ongoing for an inclusive political
system and promised all afghans rights
will be respected
there's a lot of concern about whether
women will be allowed to work that girls
can still go to school
what assurances can you give to women
and girls that their rights will be
protected
islamic emirate is committed to the
right of women within the framework of
sharia
our women have the same rights they are
going to be working shoulder to shoulder
with us
we want to assure the international
community there will be no
discrimination against women but of
course within our religious framework
but after years of war trust is hard to
come by on day two of taliban rule in
kabul there were few women on the
streets
as a woman
should i be scared of the taliban
no why should you be scared of us you
should never be afraid of us
the taliban has asked everyone in kabul
to continue their lives as usual and
keep going to work it is also declared
an amnesty for all those who worked
against the armed group saying all is
forgiven and that embassies and foreign
nationals should feel safe
the taliban has sought to portray itself
as more moderate than during its 1990s
rule yet people are wondering if this
really is the taliban 2.0
the situation in kabul is really good
now the taliban are here and we have
taken control of security and we will
hold it until the end the taliban have
made a number of statements that on the
surface are reassuring
um but
as their actions speak
deeper than words and it's it's very
early now it's very fluid
uh it's very hard to say
what is happening exactly
yet the taliban are in high spirits and
defiant afghanistan's days as a
battlefield are over
mujahid said he hoped people stopped
fleeing and stayed to be assets for the
nation
we have pardon everyone all those who
have fought against us
we don't want a repeat of war
we want to do away with the factors of
conflict so the islamic emirate of
afghanistan does not have any conflict
with anybody we want the fighting to end
mujahid stated journalists should remain
free and independent to critique the
group so it can improve
one journalist asked you say you can
forgive everyone but do you think the
victims can forgive you
for afghans on all sides there is a lot
of healing ahead
charlotte ballas al jazeera kabul